The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
It's 12:05, so why don't you
go ahead and take 10 more
seconds on the clicker
question today.
This is about the periodic
trends that we
discussed on Wednesday.
So specifically, what we're
asking here is as we go across
the periodic table, we want to
consider which has the smaller
ionization energy.
All right.
So, let's focus our attention
up here now, whether it's
between aluminum or whether
it's between phosphorous.
And I also wanted you to
identify why it's also
important to understand why we
have these trends, not just to
memorize the trend itself.
So, it turns out that the
majority of you got the
correct answer, which is
that it's aluminum.
The reason it's aluminum is
because aluminum has a lower z
effective, so it's not being
pulled in as tightly by the
nucleus, and if it's not being
pulled in as tightly, you're
going to have to put in less
energy in order to ionize it,
so that's why it's actually
going to have the smaller
ionization energy.
So it looks like not too many
more than half of you got this
correct, so make sure you can
look at your periodic table
and figure out how to think
about ionization energy in
terms of z effective, not just
in terms of memorizing what
that trend is.
All right, so we can go to
today's notes, and in terms of
the notes, what we're going
to start with is finishing
material that's going to be
relevant for exam 1, and I
told you on Wednesday that
actually I'd give you some
information today in terms of
what you need to do to prepare
for exam 1.
So you should have gotten two
handouts as you came in, and
if you didn't, please raise your
hand and a TA will come
to you and get you that
second handout.
But the second one says "exam
instructions and logistics."
So, if everyone can
pull that out.
So this is going to tell you
pretty much everything you
need to know in terms of getting
ready for the exam,
which is next Wednesday.
So when you go home today or
some time this weekend, make
sure you read this
page in detail.
I'm just going to go over a few
of the main points here.
So, the first is that what we're
going over notes today
and also on Monday, the exam
material ends at the end
lecture notes from lecture 9.
So that was Wednesday's class
-- not at the end of
Wednesday's class, but at the
end of the lecture notes.
So we're going to finish
up with those today.
I'll be really, really clear
when we get through them, and
that's where you can stop in
terms of studying for this.
Also, on everything that was on
problem-sets 1 through 3.
So, you turned in p-set 3 today,
but we'll have the
answers posted for you this
afternoon, so you can start
studying from p-set 3, even as
early as tonight, if you want
to, because those answers
will be there for you.
So, in terms of what it is that
you need to prepare and
bring with you for the exam, you
need to bring your MIT ID,
especially if you haven't been
showing up regularly to your
recitations and you aren't 100%
sure if your TA knows
exactly who you are, you need to
make sure you have your MIT
ID with you.
You can't take the exam unless
you're registered for the
class, and we need to make
sure we can verify that.
You also need to bring a
calculator, of course, because
we'll be solving problems that
involve calculations.
You can bring any calculator
you want, we don't actually
have restrictions for calculator
types here, but
what you can't do, is you can't
program any relevant
chemical or information about
constants in there.
It's OK to use certain
fundamental constants that
come in a lot of calculators,
so there's nothing we can do
about that.
That's OK.
If you're wondering what's OK
or what's not OK, it's very
clearly written out in this
handout, so make sure you read
through it, because it is your
responsibility to make sure
that your calculator does
not have anything extra
programmed in it.
And if you have your calculator
all set up as you
love and you don't want to
change it, then maybe you
should just go and get an $8.00
scientific calculator
that doesn't have any of the
graphing functions, because
you don't actually need them, so
that's a better option for
you, you can do that as well.
And I had mentioned several
times that you do not need to
memorize the majority of the
equations and you don't need
to memorize any physical
constants.
So if you flip the info page
over on the back here, what
you'll see is the periodic
table, this is the same one
that I've handed out in the
last two lectures -- the
periodic table without any
electron configurations.
This is exactly the sheet here,
it's exactly what you'll
get on exam day.
You'll also see that they have
all the physical constants
that you're going to need, and
also a bunch of the actual
equations that we've been using
in the first couple
weeks here.
So you don't need to memorize
any of this, you're actually
going to be handed this.
There are a few equations that
you need to memorize -- those
are the very simple -- very,
very simple equations, such as
e equals h times nu -- hopefully
you don't have to
sit down and try to memorize
that, hopefully we all know
that already.
But just to be really clear,
I've written out exactly which
equations you do have to
memorize on the front here, so
long as you know those, the
rest you can just look up.
And in terms of using these
equations in solving problems
on the exam, and also using
these constants, make sure if
you think there might be any
chance you're going to get any
little part of a problem wrong
or do a calculation
inaccurately, you need to write
out every single step of
your thinking as you write out
these problems. We can't give
you any partial credit
whatsoever if we can't see
your thought process.
So it's important to write out
the equation you use, you need
to write out the constants
that you use to
fill in that equation.
And that we need to see your
work to get full credit, and
then especially if you get
things wrong, we need to know
where it went wrong, because
we do try to give as much
partial credit as possible in
these exams, since there are a
lot of places where small
mistakes can result in the
wrong answer.
So also, along those lines in
terms of test taking, make
sure you also box your answers
and that you keep track of
significant figures and that you
also remember to include
your units.
These are just little things
that can add up, so you just
want to make sure you're
on top of those.
And your TAs on Tuesday are
going to share a lot of other
types of sort of exam strategies
in thinking about
how you can approach an exam
when we're in a time situation
like we are, so they'll share
some of their experience with
you in terms of taking
these timed exams.
So, in terms of practicing this
weekend, I mentioned that
instead of getting a problem-set
today, what I am
going to be posting is optional
extra problems. So
they're optional, but they're
very, very, very highly
encouraged that you do these,
because this is going to give
you practice for the types of
problems that are going to be
on the exam.
We're also posting a practice
exam for you to take, so after
you're completely done your
studying, it's good to have
everything done before you take
the practice exam, and
then sit down just with this
sheet here and your
calculator, and ideally a timer,
and make sure you can
do the practice exam in the
allotted amount of time.
So that way you can have an
idea if, oh, I do really
understand this but I'm a little
bit slow, maybe I need
to practice this one type of
problem a little bit longer so
I can get up to speed so I'm
going to be able to get
through all this in terms
of the exam time.
All right.
So let's move on to
today's topics.
So, as I said, we're finishing
up with what we left off with
yesterday -- or excuse
me, on Wednesday.
This includes atomic radius and
the idea of isoelectronic
atoms. So that's going to
be the end of the exam 1
material, and then we'll move
on to exam 2 material, which
is kind of exciting, because
we've been talking about just
individual atoms and ions up to
this point, and now we can
talk about molecules, so
we're going to start
talking about bonding.
So for some you that are less
interested in maybe the
physical structure of an
individual atom, now some more
exciting material for you might
be coming up if you like
to think about how, instead,
molecules behave, either
within bonding, within
themselves, or with other
molecules, that's what we're
going to be heading to
in this next unit.
So, we need to finish up
with periodic trends.
And first, on your
lecture notes, I
start with atomic radius.
I was so proud of myself getting
the lecture notes
finished early and handing them
in to CopyTech, and then
I realized we didn't do
electronegativity on Wednesday.
So, if you can flip your lecture
notes over and just
write on the blank space,
we're going to cover
electronegativity first here,
and specifically, you can go
back and fill this in to your
lecture 9 notes, if you want
to stay organized, but I just
suggest just writing it on
lecture 10 notes now
and going back.
You can still keep organized,
which hopefully most of you
like to do, and get it in the
right place in the notes.
So, when we're talking about the
idea of electronegativity,
essentially what we're talking
about is the ability for an
atom to attract electron density
from another atom.
So it's just a measure of how
much does one given atom want
to pull away electron
density from, let's
say, an adjacent atom.
So it's actually very related
to what we're talking about
when we said electron affinity,
and it's also
related to ionization energy,
and we can call
electronegativity by symbol
here, and it turns out that
it's going to be proportional
to 1/2 of the electron
affinity of a given atom, plus
the ionization energy.
So, in other words, we
can just think of
electronegativity as being the
average of that ionization
energy and the electron
affinity.
This should make sense, because
if an atom has a very
high electron affinity, that
means it's really happy taking
an electron from another atom,
or taking a free electron --
that that's very favorable.
If something has a high
ionization energy, it means
that it really, really,
really does not want
to give up an electron.
So you can think about how these
2 things combined are
going to be electronegativity,
which is a measure of how much
an atom wants to pull electron
density away
from another atom.
So, if we think about
electronegativity as a
periodic trend, we can just draw
our nice periodic table
here, and let's separate
it into quadrants.
So if we think about the upper
right hand part of the
quadrant, well, this is where
we're going to have high
electron affinity and high
ionization energy, so we're
also going to see high
electronegativity here.
And in contrast, in the lower
left hand part of the periodic
table, these 2 quantities are
low, so also what we're going
to see is low electronegativity.
And if we talk about what's
going on in areas, or with
atoms that have high
electronegativity, and we
think about whether they're
electron donors or electron
acceptors, what would you expect
for an atom that has
high electronegativity?
Is it going to be an electron
donor or acceptor?
Great.
Yup, it's going to be an
electron acceptor, it wants to
accept electrons, it wants to
accept electron density.
So, in contrast, if it has a
low electronegativity, this
then is going to be
an electron donor.
All right, so it's very
common to talk about
electronegativity of different
atoms, and you can look up
tables of these.
Often what you'll see is not
a table based on this
definition, but something that's
called the Pauling
definition of electronegativity,
but it's
exactly the same idea and the
same trend as this more
numerical way to think about
what the meaning of
electronegativity is.
All right, so now we can move
on to the start of today's
notes, which is atomic radius.
So this, in fact, is going to
be our last principle that
we're going to talk about in
terms of periodic trends.
So this is actually the most
straightforward, so sometimes
it's nice to end with the
easiest concept, and that's
what we're doing here.
And if we're talking about
atomic radius, essentially
we're talking about
atomic size.
And immediately it should
probably come into your head
that we don't actually have an
atomic radius that we can talk
about, right?
What I just spent many lectures
discussing is the
fact that we can not know how
far away an electron is from
the nucleus, so we can't
actually know the radius of a
certain atom.
And that's true.
An atom's not a defined
sphere, for example.
We can't define it as an exact
radius in terms of the
definition we might think
of classically.
So, keep that in mind when we're
talking about atomic
radius, I'm not suddenly
changing my story and saying,
yes, we do have a
distinct radius.
Instead, what people have done
is come up with different ways
to think about how they
can define a radius.
And one common way to think
about it, is to think about
the value of r, or the radius,
below which 90% of that
electron density is going
to be contained.
So we're not saying it's
all the electron
density, it's just 90%.
Because we know as we go to
infinity, even though the
density gets smaller and smaller
and smaller, we still
have electron density very far
away from the nucleus.
So, what we're going to define
is just let's just capture 90%
of that electron density.
So, that's one way to think
about it, and there's also
another way, and this
is the way that your
book presents it.
If you, in fact, have two of
the same atom right next to
each other, let's say you have a
crystal, or let's say you're
talking about a metal, what you
can do is just look at the
distance between the two nuclei,
and split that in 1/2,
and take the atomic
radius that way.
So, these are two different
definitions of how to think
about atomic radius, but really
what you find when
these are measured is they
come up with almost the
identical values, so there are
tables you can look up of
atomic radii and see these
values, and you can trust them
that, yes, they work for both
this definition and for this
definition here,
in most cases.
And what we've been talking
about with all of these
properties are, of course, how
can we figure out what that is
for a certain atom by looking
at the periodic table, so we
want to think about
the periodic
trend for atomic radius.
And we know as we go across a
row in the periodic table,
what's happening is that z
effective or the effective
pull on the nucleus
is increasing.
So would you expect, therefore,
as we go across a
row for the atomic radius, to
increase or to decrease?
Good.
OK, yes.
We are expecting to see that
it decreases because it's
feeling a stronger pull, all the
electrons are being pulled
in closer to the nucleus, so
that atomic size is going to
get smaller.
This is in contrast to what's
happening as we go down a
periodic table.
So as we go down we're now
adding electrons to further
and further away shells, so
what we're going to see is
that the atomic radius is going
to increase as we're
going down the periodic table.
And we can look at
an example here.
If we start in the upper left
hand corner of the periodic
table with lithium, you can
see that as we go down the
table, what you're seeing is
that that atomic radius is
actually increasing,
as we would expect.
Whereas, if we go across a row,
what we see is that the
atomic radius is decreasing.
So, again, this is one of the
more straightforward trends.
You just need to remember
what's happening to z
effective, which really tells
us what's happening with all
the trends, and once you know
z effective, you can figure
out, for example, what direction
the atomic radius
should be going into.
So, that's it for
periodic trends.
We have talked about four
different ones.
We talked about ionization
energy, electron affinity, we
talked about electronegativity,
which is
just kind of a combination of
the first two, and then ended
with atomic radius here.
And what you might have noted
is although we described how
to make predictions about these
properties, I didn't
talk too much about what it
actually means, what the
ramifications of these different
properties are.
And the reason we didn't do that
is because we're actually
going to spend much of the rest
of the course relating
these different properties to
the properties of molecules in
terms of bonding, and also in
terms of chemical reactions.
So, for example, if we have a
very electronegative atom
within a certain molecule, what
you'll actually find is
that it does affect how the
molecule is going to take part
in different chemical or
biological reactions.
And this will become more and
more clear as we actually talk
about these reactions and
talk about bonding.
But you need to be able to
predict what kind of
properties a certain atom's
going to have within a
molecule, whether you're talking
about something, for
example, that's very
electronegative, or something
that is not electronegative at
all, it is going to make a
difference in terms of thinking
about how molecules
are structured and
also how they
interact with other molecules.
However, I can give you at least
one example while we're
still on just talking about
atoms. So we haven't gotten to
molecules yet, we're just
talking about single atoms or
single ions, but what's nice
is just talking about this
very straightforward principle
of atomic radius.
We can already use that in terms
of single ions to think
about a really complex
biological issue, which is to
talk about ion channels.
So, that is just a quick example
for some of you, you
might be very familiar with ion
channels, others might not
know what these are, so I'll
just tell you quite briefly
that ion channels are
these very massive
transmembrane proteins.
Essentially, what they are is
it's a protein that spans the
membrane of a cell.
And what they do is they
regulate the influx of ions
across that cell.
So the influx of ions from the
outside of the cell to the
inside of the cell,
for example.
And you can think of ion
channels as being gated, by
gated it means the gate can be
closed and no ions are going
through, as in this case here.
Or you can talk about the gate
being open, and in this case,
you can see that you will
have an influx of ions.
So, ion channels are important
for maintaining a voltage
difference between the inside of
the cell and outside of the
cell, and they're found in all
sorts of cell types in your
body, but if you think about
where they're most prevalent,
it turns out that they're most
prevalent in muscle cells and
also in nerve cells,
so in your neurons.
And essentially, what they do
in neurons is they underlie
those nerve impulses, or those,
essentially what we
call electrical signaling
between neurons -- you might
also call that the action
potential of the neurons.
So essentially, they regulate
this action potential, and
they do so by helping to
establish and then control the
voltage gradient within the
cells. so, essentially,
they're establishing or
controlling or changing the
difference between the charge
inside the cell and the charge
outside cell.
And when we talk about any type
of ion channel, there are
just tons of different kinds of
ion channels, and you can
characterize them in a
few different ways.
So, for example, you could
characterize them in terms of
how they're gated, and basically
how they open or
close -- that's one way to talk
about different types.
Another way to talk about
different types is to think
about which ion they're
selected for.
And all ion channels are
selective for a single type of
ion, and we can think about
how that selectivity takes
place, and that's where this
idea of atomic radius is going
to become very important.
So, for example, if we look at
sodium channels, and sodium
channels are some of the
particularly prevalent ones
when we're talking about
neurons, if you think about
the cell membrane, and this
little green cartoon is me
trying to show a sodium channel
here, and in this
case, you can see that it's
closed, such that no ions are
getting through.
However, when that gate is
opened, the sodium channel is
now going to be incredibly
selective and only let through
sodium ions and no other
type of ion.
And this is really interesting
to think about because you can
imagine in our body we have
concentrations of all types of
ions, and specifically, some
seem very, very similar to
each other.
So we could think about
comparing the potassium ion to
a sodium ion.
They have the same charge
of plus one.
The only thing that's different
is that they're one
down on the periodic table,
potassium is down one row, so
it's going to be a little
bigger, but when we're
thinking about size, it maybe
does not seem that significant
to talk about the size.
But what we find out
is that it is.
So, what happens, this is
another view of a sodium
channel, so this is actually
looking a little bit more at
the protein structure.
What all of these channels
have is what's called a
selectivity filter, so this
filter filters out the type of
ion that's going to be
allowed through.
And there's two parts
of the filter.
First we need to select
for actual charge.
So the way that it does this
is the filter is actually
lined with all of this negative
charge, and for those
of you that are more into
biology or biochemistry,
that's because of negatively
charged amino acid residues,
but all you need to think about
is that it has negative
charge in the inside of this
pore, and what happens then is
that if something has a positive
charge, it's going to
be stabilized to enter this
pore, whereas any negative
ions are going to be repelled.
So that's the first step in
being selective, but now how
do we differentiate between
these sodium
and potassium ions.
And the answer is just really
beautifully simple, and it's
just that the pore gets really,
really tiny, to the
point that it gets so small that
all that can fit through
this pore is one a single ion,
one single sodium ion,
solvated by one single
water molecule.
And that's all that's big enough
to pass through or
small enough to pass through.
And if we go up even just one
row on the periodic table to
potassium, what we actually see
is now that it's going to
be too large, and, in fact, a
potassium solvated with one
water molecule won't go
through our channel.
So, this is just one example
of how these properties can
already, even our understanding
just talking
about single atoms, can already
make an impact in
these biological systems. And
actually, a question that
might come up, I just explained,
the sodium channel,
you might say, well, how do
potassium channels work then,
because I can understand how you
can filter something big
out, but how do you filter
out something small.
And it turns out that size
exclusion is also the
principle that's in play with
potassium channels as well,
but in this case it's a little
more complex, because what
happens is these negative
residues the are in the pore
need to stabilize the potassium
as it goes through,
and the potassium is large
enough to make all the
contacts it needs, but the
sodium, which you can picture
being smaller, actually can't
reach all of the stabilizing
charges that it needs to to
get through the pore.
So, again, it is based on size,
it's a little bit less
intuitive than the idea of just
straining out all of the
potassium ions.
But again, many of these ion
channels have this size
exclusion pore, it's a very
important part of them.
All right, so that was a quick
aside on thinking about how
these properties can,
in fact, relate to
something in our body.
Let's move on to the last topic
in terms of this first
exam, which is thinking about
the idea of isoelectronic
atoms, or isoelectronic ions.
And isoelectronic is very
straightforward, it just means
having the same electron
configuration.
The easiest way to look at this
is just to do an example.
So let's take the
example of neon.
This has the electron
configuration of 1 s 2, 2
s 2, and 2 p 6.
It looks like we're cut off the
screen a little bit here,
but you can see I've just
circled it there.
So we can go ahead and think
about, well, are there any
other atoms that are going
to have the same electron
configuration?
The answer to that is definitely
no -- if they had
the same electron configuration,
they would, in
fact, be neon.
But we can think about different
ions that have this
electron configuration.
So for example, if we think
about fluorine, that has an
electron configuration of 1 s
2, 2 s 2, 2 p 5, so all we
would need to do is add one more
electron to get the same
configuration as for neon.
So if we want to write out what
that would be, it would
just be to say that f minus is
isoelectronic with neon.
So, we can say that -- if we
have neon here and we want to
think about what's
isoelectronic, f minus would
be isoelectronic.
We also have oxygen -- what
would the charge on oxygen be?
Um-hmm, right.
2 minus.
Then also, nitrogen, 3 minus --
these are all going to be
isoelectronic with neon.
We can go in the other
direction, so let's go to
sodium, but we would need to
take away an electron to make
it isoelectronic.
So we would say sodium plus,
or magnesium 2 plus, we can
just keep going -- aluminum 3
plus, silicone 4 plus, and we
can go on and on in either
direction all the way across
and down the periodic table.
So, that's the idea of
isoelectronic ions.
These are all isoelectronic,
they all have the same
electron configuration.
And we can also think
about going back to
atomic size for a second.
What the relationship is between
these ions and their
parent atoms. So, for example,
if we think of the fluorine
minus case, would you expect
fluorine minus to be larger or
smaller than neutral fluorine?
Okay.
I heard mostly larger, but a
little bit of a mix in there,
and it turns out that
larger is correct.
And we can think about why --
essentially we have fluorine
and now we're adding
another electron.
So you can picture that fluorine
is going to get
larger in this case.
And that would be true
for all of the
negatively charged ions.
So, by the same logic, that
means that all of our
positively charged ions are, in
fact, going to be smaller
in terms of radius, compared
to their neutral parents.
Not only are we taking away an
electron here, but we're also
going to decrease shielding,
so the electrons that are
already in there are going to
feel a higher z effective and
will be pulling and the atom
will be getting smaller.
And this is just a picture
showing some of these sizes
with their parent.
So, for example, a lithium here,
you can see how lithium
plus is smaller than the actual
lithium atom in its
neutral state.
Whereas for fluorine, fluorine
is smaller than f minus is the
one that's the outer
shell shown here.
So, let's do a clicker question
on isoelectronic
atoms. And now we're asking you
to look at krypton, so the
atomic mass is 36.
You can actually just grab
that handout, the second
handout on the exam and look at
the periodic table there.
So, which of the following ions
listed is isoelectronic
with krypton?
OK, let's take 10
seconds on that.
OK, good.
This might be our all-time
high, 89% got this right.
This is great.
So, selenium 2 minus is what's
going to be isoelectronic,
because if you add two electrons
to selenium, you'll
get the same electron
configuration that you have
for krypton here.
OK, I think we can safely
go back to notes.
So, I said I would announce
it, that's the
end of exam 1 material.
So, if you compartmentalize
things in your brain in
certain ways, put that off into
the end of the exam 1
part of your brain, and
now we're going to
move on to exam 2.
Remember, for exam 2, you
still need to know and
understand everything you
learned in exam 1, but you can
put off learning it completely
until we get through, at
least, next Wednesday before we
start maybe spending time
on these concepts outside
of class.
So, we're going to start with
talking about bonding, and any
time we have a chemical bond,
basically what we're talking
about is having two atoms where
the arrangement of their
nuclei and they're electrons are
such that the bonded atoms
results in a lower energy than
for the separate atoms. So we
know we always want to have
our systems in as low an
energy as possible, so it makes
sense that a bond would
happen any time we got a lower
energy when we combine two
atoms, versus when we
keep them separate.
So specifically, today
we're going to talk
about covalent bonds.
A covalent bond is any time we
have a pair of electrons that
is shared between two different
atoms. And the key
word for covalent bonds is
the idea of being shared.
The two electrons, for example,
we see in the h 2
molecule, they don't belong to
one or the other atom, they're
actually shared.
And what we'll see later, is
that the sharing is not always
equal -- in the case
of h 2, it is
completely equal sharing.
In some cases, because of things
like electronegativity,
one atom will take away more of
the electron density than
the other atom, but they're
still shared, even if they're
not always evenly shared.
So, in talking about covalent
bonds, we should be able to
still apply a more general
definition of a chemical bond,
which should tell us that the
h 2 molecule is going to be
lower in energy than if we
looked at 2 separate hydrogen
atom molecules.
So, let's see if that's
actually the case.
So if I tell you that the energy
for single hydrogen
atom is negative 13 12
kilojoules per mole.
If we want to talk about two
hydrogen atoms, then we just
need to double that, so that's
going to be negative 2 6 2 4
kilojoules per mole that we're
talking about in terms of a
single hydrogen atom.
So, let's compare this to the
energy of the h 2 molecule,
and we find that that's
negative 3,048
kilojoules per mole.
So, in fact, yes, we did confirm
that these covalent
bond, at least in the case of
hydrogen, we have confirmed by
the numbers that we are at a
lower energy state when we
talk about the bonded atom
versus the individual atom.
And when we talk about covalent
bonds, there's 2
properties that we'll mostly
focus on, and that's going to
be thinking about the bond
strength or the energy by
which it stabilized
when it bonds.
And we can also talk about the
bond length, so we might be
interested in what the bond
length is, what the distance
between these two nuclei are.
And we can actually better
visualize this if we plot how
that energy changes
as a function of
internuclear distance.
And when I say internuclear
distance, we actually call
this r here.
It's kind of ironic that we put
this in the same lecture
as we talk about atomic radii,
which we also call r, but
they're two different r's,
so you need to keep them
separated in terms of what
you're talking about.
When we're talking about r for
internuclear distance, we're
talking about the distance
between two different nuclei
in a bond, in a covalent bond.
So, if we look at this graph
where what we're charting is
the internuclear distance, so
the distance between these two
hydrogen atoms, as a function
of energy, what we are going
to see is a curve that looks
like this -- this is the
general curve that you'll see
for any covalent bond, and
we'll explain where that
comes from in a minute.
I want to point out that the
zero energy is defined as when
you have a naked proton where
the electron has popped out --
that's what we've defined as
zero energy up to this point
when we're talking about single
atoms. So, for starters
we'll keep that as our zero
energy, we're going to change
it soon to make something that
makes more sense in terms of
bonding, but we'll keep
that as zero for now.
So, we see that the two h atoms
separate have a certain
energy that's lower than
when the electron's
not with the atom.
And then even lower
down, we have our
bonded hydrogen molecule.
So, we can think about the
different kinds of
interactions that are
taking place.
I said what hold the bonds
together, what holds two atoms
together is the attractive force
we have between each
electron and the
other nucleus.
That's the huge force that we're
talking about in terms
of making a bond stable, but
there are also repulsive
forces, so you can imagine
we're going to have
electron-electron repulsion
between the two electrons if
we're bringing them
closer together.
And the real killer is if we get
too close we're even going
to have nuclear-nuclear
repulsion between the nuclei
of the two atoms.
So, this makes this chart shown
in pink make a lot more
sense, because if we're way
out at very far distances,
essentially what we have here
is we're talking about two
separate atoms. They're not
interacting at all so that's
why the energy is the same as
that for two individual atoms,
that's what we're
dealing with.
As we get closer together,
we start get lower
and lower in energy.
The reason is because the
predominant force at this
point is going to be the
attraction that's being felt
between the nuclei and the
electrons in each of the
atoms. At some point you're
going to hit a well here,
which is the point where it's
most stabilized or at it's
lowest energy.
So, when we think about a bond
length, this is going to be
the length of our bond here,
that makes sense because it's
going to want to be at
that distance that
minimizes the energy.
But as we keep getting closer,
even though as we get closer,
the attraction is going to get
stronger between the two
nuclei and the electrons.
We're also going to start to
have the repulsive forces
become more prominent here, and,
in fact, they take over
at some point, becoming the more
prevalent of the forces,
so as you get closer, the
electron-electron repulsions,
and eventually the
nucleus-nucleus repulsion is
going to mean that your energy
is just absolutely
skyrocketing, so it just keeps
going up and up as you get
closer to zero here.
So, when we want to talk about
the information that we can
get out of looking at a chart
like this, well, the first
thing I did tell you was that
this is going to be the bond
length, so the distance r where
the energy is lowest,
but we can also talk about
something called dissociation
energy, that's going to be this
distance right here or
the energy that is this value.
And the dissociation energy is
very intuitive in terms of
what it means, it means how much
energy you need to put
into the molecule in order to
disassociate it into its
individual atoms. And so we can
actually think about how
do we calculate what the
dissociation energy should be
for h 2, so let's go
ahead and do this.
So, if we talk about
dissociating h 2, we're going
from the h 2 molecule, and
breaking this bond right in
half, so we now have
two individual
hydrogen atoms here.
So we need to take the energy
for the two atoms, which we
know is -- so let's take our
dissociation energy is going
to be equal to negative 2 6 2 4
kilojoules per mole, and we
want to subtract the energy of
the hydrogen molecule itself,
so that's going to be negative
3 0 4 8 kilojoules per mole.
So, what we get for the
disassociation energy for a
hydrogen atom is 424 kilojoules
per mole.
So what that means is that's how
much energy we would have
to put in to a hydrogen molecule
in order to get it to
split apart into
its two atoms.
So, another way to talk about
dissociation energy is simply
to call it bond strength, it's
the same thing, they're equal
to each other.
If we know that this is it the
dissociation energy for a
hydrogen atom, we can also say
the bond strength for hydrogen
molecule is 424.
So, there's actually another way
to graph it where we can
directly graph the dissociation
energy or the
bond strengths.
So I said before when we were
talking about single atoms, we
always define the zero energy
as when an electron was
actually ejected, but now, when
we talk about chemical
reactions taking place, it's
very, very rare that we're
actually going to be talking
about anything that gets to
this point here.
It's much more relevant to set
our zero point energy as the
separation of a bond in terms of
talking about the reactions
that we'll usually be
dealing with here.
So, let's change our graph where
we now have this zero
point set as the two individuals
hydrogen atoms,
and then we see that our h 2
molecule is at the negative of
the dissociation energy, or the
negative what that bond
strength is.
So we know what that number
would be, it would be negative
424 kilojoules per mole
that we see here.
So, what this let's us do now
is directly compare, for
example, the strength of a bond
in terms of a hydrogen
atom and hydrogen molecule,
compared to any kind of
molecule that we want to
graph on top of it.
So, let's, for example,
look at nitrogen.
So n 2, we can do the chart
here in green, so it's the
green dotted line, and what
we see is that we have now
defined this energy
as where the 2
nitrogen atoms are separated.
So what we can actually directly
compare is the
dissociation energy or the
bond strength of nitrogen
versus hydrogen.
So, if we think about this,
which would you say has a
stronger bond?
Is it going to be hydrogen
or nitrogen?
Yup, it's going to
be nitrogen.
And the reason we can see that
by looking at this graph is
that we see that nitrogen when
it's bonded is in an even
lower well than we
saw for hydrogen.
It's going to be a stronger
bond because it's more
stabilized when it when it comes
together as a molecule.
We can also think about the
distance, the bond distance.
So, which would you
say is going to be
shorter in this case?
Is a hydrogen bond shorter, or
is a nitrogen-nitrogen triple
bond going to be shorter?
Um-hmm, again, we can
get this information
directly from our graph.
We see that the radius is
shorter, so that means that
the nitrogen-nitrogen bond
is going to be shorter.
We can know this information
even if we just knew that the
bond was stronger, we wouldn't
need to look at a graph here,
because it turns out that if you
have a stronger bond, that
also means that you have a
shorter bond -- those ywo are
correlated.
And something that we'll see
later on is that triple bonds,
for example, are going to be
stronger than a corresponding
double bond or a corresponding
single bond.
So, if we talked about a
nitrogen-nitrogen single
versus double versus triple
bond, the triple bond will be
the shortest and it will
be the strongest.
So, that's basically the idea
of how we are going to be
thinking about covalent bonds.
It's also important, once we
start talking about molecules,
to have a way to represent them,
and also to be able to
look at a shorthand notation
for a certain molecule and
understand what the bond is.
So, for example, down here I
wrote that it was n 2 and that
it was h 2, but when I re-wrote
the molecules up
here, you saw that it's an h
h single bond where it's a
nitrogen-nitrogen triple bond.
So any chemist should be able
to just look at n 2 and know
that it's a triple bond, but
that's not something that
we've learned how did to do
yet, so let's go ahead and
start a new topic that's going
to allow us to have some sort
of sense of what the valence
electron configuration, which
includes whether something's a
single or double or a triple
bond can be figured out for
any given molecule.
So, to do this, what I'm going
to do is introduce the topic
of Lewis structures.
We're going to really get into
this next class, but I just
want to introduce it to you to
give us a start, and many of
you have used Lewis structures
in high school, but we'll be
doing some much more challenging
Lewis structures,
I can assure you, in
this class here.
So, a Lewis structure is
basically an organizing
property of bonding, of
molecules, which is the idea
that when we're thinking about
bonding, the key is to achieve
a full valence shell in each of
the individual atoms. So we
want to have in an h h bond, for
example, a full shell for
each of the hydrogen atoms.
And G.N. Lewis is the
scientist that is credited, and
who did, in fact, come up
with this idea for the way to
represent this, so the other
parts of this idea, another way
to phrase it is that the
electrons are going to be
distributed in such a way that
we have what are called full
octets for each of the atoms,
and basically that's the same
thing as saying we have a full
valence shell, and this is
something that Lewis was able
to recognize very, very early,
way before we had quantum
mechanics to describe what these
orbitals were, but it
makes sense a full valence shell
means for most atoms
that we have a full s orbital
plus a full p orbital, so
we're going to have a total of
four orbitals that are each
filled with eight electrons, so
that's why we see that we
need an octet here.
And the idea is that when you do
these Lewis dot structures,
we're representing electrons
with dots, which we'll see in
a minute, and each
dot is going to
represent a valence electron.
So, hopefully, you remember
what we mean by valence
electrons versus
core electrons.
Core electrons are all those
electrons held in really tight
with the nucleus in the inner
shells, whereas the valence
electrons are only those
electrons that are in the
outer-most shell, or at your
highest value of n of the
principal quantum number.
So, Lewis structures are really
a model for a way to
think about what the valence
electron configuration is, and
as I said, it's not based on
quantum mechanics, it's
something that Lewis observed
far, far before quantum
mechanics were discovered.
So he came up with the ideas
that led to the idea of Lewis
structures in the very
early 1900's.
So you might ask well, why are
we using this model if it
clearly doesn't take into
account quantum mechanics?
And the reason that we use it
is that it is incredibly
accurate, and allows us to very,
very quickly predict and
to predict accurately, in most
cases, what the electron
configuration of molecules
are going to be.
So this is really useful.
We don't always want to go
and solve the Schrodinger
equation, and in fact, once we
start talking about molecules,
I can imagine none of you, as
much as you love math or
physics, want to be trying
to solve this Schrodinger
equation in that case either.
So, what Lewis structures allow
us to do is over 90% of
the time be correct in terms
of figuring out what the
electron configuration is.
And we won't just use
them in this class.
If you actually go to any of the
chemistry labs at MIT, if
you go over to building 18 and
look in the organic labs where
they're synthesizing new
molecules or making up new
reactions, what you'll see if
you open anyone's notebook,
their lab notebook, assuming
they keep a nice lab notebook,
is that they will have Lewis
structures drawn in there that
explain the reactions that
they're going to be
doing for that day.
And I mean this means way past
all the chemistry they've
taken, they're now graduate
students or they're now
professors, and they're still
writing out Lewis structures.
Now they're writing a more
abbreviated form, which you'll
probably get to if you take
organic chemistry, but really
it's the exact same idea.
And this goes all the
way back to 1902.
In fact, Lewis was an American
scientist, so he was trained
in America, and he actually was
a professor here at MIT
from 1905 all the way to about
1911 or 1912, and these are
some notes from 1902, and you
can't see them very well, but
this was essentially an early
form of Lewis structures, and
this was called the
cubicle atom.
So, basically what he's showing
in these cubes is that
there are eight spaces that
need to be filled up
to have a full cube.
So in order to fill them, he
would have to have eight
electrons or an octet
around the cubes.
So what we're seeing is this
is notes from 1902 -- he
actually didn't publish any of
this work or these ideas that
led to Lewis structures until
1916, but his early class
notes were used as evidence
about how long ago he actually
came up with the idea of it.
So it's really neat to think
that your counterparts 100
years ago right here at MIT
could have been sitting in a
class where they had Lewis as
their lecturer, and he's
putting forth these ideas --
these are actually his lecture
notes, even though it wasn't
even published yet, and giving
this idea of Lewis structure,
which is exactly what we keep
using today in order to make
a lot of these predictions.
So, let's see how some of this
works, and hopefully your
counterparts from 100 years
ago would also be able to
think about how this works, even
if they don't have the
quantum mechanics behind
the individual electron
configurations for atoms. So
I said that we want to be
talking about valence electrons
here, so that means
if we're talking about, for
example, the octet rule for an
f f molecule where we have two
fluorine atoms, we need to
write the valence electrons
as dots around them.
So let's do a quick clicker
question, and you tell me how
many valence electrons
does fluorine have?
Remember, valence electrons
are different from core,
they're only the outer-most
electrons in
the outer-most shell.
So, 10 seconds on this,
this should
be fast. OK, great.
Good job on the clicker
questions today.
So we have seven valence
electrons.
So, let's go back to the notes,
and let's fill these
in, seven electrons.
Another way you could have
known them was to look at
Lewis' notes here, where if look
at this box carefully you
see there are seven dots around
the cube, so there are
his seven valence electrons.
So, we see is when we use the
octet rule to look at fluorine
molecule, we're combining two
fluorine atoms, and what we
end up with is an f f molecule
where they're sharing two
electrons, so making
that covalent bond.
But that each individual
fluorine atom has eight
electrons, or full
octet around it.
We can think about where those
electrons came from, so we got
seven from the blue electrons
here, seven as shown in green
here, but each individual
fluorine atom has eight, even
though two of those are being
shared between both of them.
So, the octet rule is a general
rule that you'll for
all of the atoms. There are some
exceptions, which we'll
get to later, but the only a
big exception here is with
hydrogen, which has a special
stability that's associated
with two electrons.
This should make a lot of sense,
because we know that a
hydrogen has 1 s as it's
outer-most or valence orbital,
so it can be filled up just
with two 1 s electrons.
And we give different names,
depending on what kind of
electrons we're dealing with,
so, for example, with h c l
here, we can talk about
having bonded
versus lone pair electrons.
So, in terms of the c l atom,
we need to talk about each
atom individually.
How many bonding electrons
does c l have?
All right.
Let's see, we've got a mixed
response here, it turns out it
has two bonding electrons.
I heard some people say one,
and that's a good guess,
remember they're actually
sharing.
So these two electrons, they
belong to chlorine, they also
belong to hydrogen, but they
do, in fact, belong to
chlorine as well.
There's no one person owning
them, so they both have two
electrons here that
are bonding.
So how many lone pair electrons
do we have?
OK.
I hear six and three, so both
are sort of right, we have 6
lone pair electrons,
which means that we
have three lone pairs.
So, in terms of thinking about
how to draw a Lewis structure,
I won't go through this today
or any day in terms of just
reading through the rules, you
can read that yourself.
But what we'll do is go through
each of these rules in
terms of an example.
So, what will start with on
Monday is doing the most
simple example of methane
using these
Lewis structure rules.
So, don't forget to study this
weekend and get those extra
practice problems from
the course website.